salut tout le monde je suis pour grüt au
tchad plus précisément dans un hôpital
de la capitale n'djamena actuellement
dans le pays il ya des milliers
d'enfants qui souffrent de malnutrition
aiguë sévère c'est la forme la plus
grave de malnutrition j'ai un mois il ya
soixante cinq enfants qui sont pris en
charge par des humanitaires et des
médecins je vais vous montrer comment il
les soigne et quels sont leurs besoins
sur place
[Musique]
allez on
la plupart des enfants qui sont dans
l'hôpital sont des enfants en bas âge
c'est à dire qu'ils ont entre 0 et 5 ans
c'est vraiment soin des bébés soient des
très jeunes enfants parce que c'est à
cette période là que la croissance est
la plus importante et c'est à ces
périodes là qu'ils ont besoin
d'énormément de nutriments et d'une
bonne alimentation
[Musique]
on a fait un survol intensif par rapport
à cet enfant parce qu'il était arrivé
avec un débours décennies
aujourd'hui son état s'améliore sa
fréquence cardiaque s'améliore il est à
131 battements par minute dans cet
enfant a déjà eu aussi milité de sortir
de la réanimation vers le sans intention
de bloquer
[Musique]
un enfant qui souffre de malnutrition
sévère aiguë en fait c'est un enfant qui
est gravement sous alimentés il a plein
carences en micronutriments comme le fer
l'yonne ou encore la vitamine à hilla
les muscles atrophiés ils peuvent avoir
des oedèmes ventre au travers le ventre
très complet et souvent ils ont des
complications médicales qui s'achevait
par dessus c'est à dire qu'ils ont des
difficultés respiratoires ou cardiaques
et ils ont tous leurs organes vitaux qui
fonctionne au ralenti donc c'est pour ça
que leur pronostic vital est souvent
engagés
sentiment à la kalach passion neuf mois
elle a des problèmes pour
460 arrivé avec quatre il descend c'est
un enfant noir monitrice en neuf mois il
peut faire au moins six kilos est
obligé de la personne
là on a mis les besoins de base on a
aussi le positionnement on cherche
toujours à faire une position
pour permettre de mieux respirer des
positions venir à 6
[Musique]
étudier le couvert
les mamans généralement elles sont en
train de donner le repas du matin au
bébé et pour qu'il récupère vite on leur
donne ce qu'on appelle du jump in est
c'est une pâte alimentaire qui est riche
en nutriments par exemple il ya beaucoup
de fer et les quantités qui leur donne
c'est en fonction d'une fois que fait le
bd
[Musique]
moi je suis déjà venu au tchad en 2018
pour parler de la malnutrition sévère
aiguë à l'époque il y avait un gros pic
de la maladie dans sa forme la plus
grave chez les enfants de moins de cinq
ans il y avait environ 500000 gamins
dans tout pays qui étaient concernés par
cette maladie donc c'est un chiffre
énorme et cette année le plus gros
problème c'est qu'ils ont du mal à se
réapprovisionner les ong les hôpitaux en
pleine peanuts dont ils ont besoin d'une
mobilisation internationale des
institutions là des bailleurs de fonds
pour récupérer du plumpy'nut et subvenir
aux besoins des enfants on a franchement
un gant blanc pour de l'âme par rapport
à
l'approvisionnement de maintenance parce
que à des cultures partout il ya un
besoin énorme un besoin énorme le taux
national au niveau du chan si on trouve
un grand instant que ça va beaucoup
aider la population aujourd'hui la
situation s'empire de jour en jour parce
que quand vous faites la ville
les journées encore les gens n'ont pas
de quoi manger et la situation est
toujours grave et c'est vous que vous
allez voir aussi la vie très chère etc à
la vie est très chère les gens n'ont pas
de quoi manger et une famille s'installe
le
le tout la tête
son état santé de cet enfant là on a vu
qu'il est en train d'être une anémie
sévère et inanimé de compenser
nécessitant une transfusion sanguine
donc on a goûté l'enfant il est des deux
groupes au plus et voilà le sens est
déjà arrivé on a mis sur 6 papes et
voilà on va commencer la transfusion
sanguine
[Musique]
fatima faire l'objet d'une surveillance
très rapprochées toute l'année parce
qu'elle a une longue journée elle est
épuisée donc elle a dû beaucoup lutté
dans le vent il songé de la monitorer la
nuit de très près
[Musique]
une
comment ça s'est passé cette nuit la
garde était agitée c'est vraiment agité
parce que
et avec du jarret par des restaurateurs
de bain de bébé qui ont faim ils ont
fait un arrêt cardio respiratoire
mais prenez mon premier bébé c'était
fatigant
l'équipe des médecins les infirmières
lauréats même effectivement avec de
l'adrénaline
massage cardiaque externe
la santé nationaux masque mais
malheureusement fatigue on a passé le
vécu on n'a pas pu la récupérer
[Musique]
dans les hôpitaux on s'occupe de la
malnutrition aiguë sévère la plupart des
enfants arrivent à être soignés peuvent
rentrer chez eux rapidement avec leurs
parents mais il ya quand même un taux de
mortalité très élevée par exemple ici
dans cet hôpital il est de 7 à 8% ça
fait presque un enfant par jour qui
décède à cause de cette maladie il faut
aussi savoir qu' il ya beaucoup de
familles qui vivent dans des régions
reculées ou dangereuses du tchad il n'y
a pas de système de santé ils n'ont pas
accès à des centres de soins donc les
enfants dans ces familles ne rentre pas
dans les statistiques nationales
[Musique]
allez on va
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
de quelques
très heureux parce qu'il est admis avec
un état qui n'est pas bon et il peut
même pas se tenir débout quand il était
arrivé et aujourd'hui je dis bravo à
toute l'équipe
bravo aussi à la maman qui a foncé sur
la prise en charge de son enfant
aujourd'hui son enfant à manger de
finale pina d'où le matin passé à
l'aller vallier et puis voilà on peut
les débarrasser des savoirs venus pour
le mettre sous traitement par voie orale
[Musique]
voyant phase de transition et
de même la libérer pour qu'il puisse
rentrer
je suis très content dit
[Musique]
il est blessé
à la cheville face à tarbes et l'italie
goran maric
finit par là ce péché de l'homme des
chili link chili à la chine qu'elle
est chez les malades tamesna wade voilà
les déchets les caraïbes toutes les
mamans avant de rentrer avec un petit
qui va mieux elles ont un cours de
cuisine pédagogique dans lequel elles
apprennent à fabriquer et cuisiner une
bouille et enrichie à base de denrées
alimentaires assez simple à trouver sur
n'importe quel marché au tchad et qui
coûte pas très cher comme le maïs ou le
sorgho et cette bouille et enrichie avec
le plumpy'nut à la pâte alimentaire en
général ça suffit pour la croissance des
enfants
téléfilm automne
kurt ni
canada
mais l'imam à karachi la mode est un
dictateur par
téléphone
vendredi
matin
le sourire
mais celle ci fait d'habitude la ravit
petits
[Musique]
bon
al mahatta mishima jada
teixido
halde à nada el abida
pourquoi ça c'est aussi important qu
elle sache le faire il faudrait
expliquer la malnutrition c'est quoi et
quel est le signe de la malnutrition
dans la communauté maintenant nous on se
bat sur la sur la périmètre brachial 1,6
et rouge ça nous indique déjà que
l'enfant doit partir déjà dans les
centres santé il faut il ne faut pas
tarder si ces jo non il faut donner de
conseils plus que normalement augmente
la quantité de bruits l'enfant il faut
qu'elle mène enfants aussi il faut que
l'enfant me prends ma soupe c'est pour
révéler vraiment l'âme artistes ont fait
succès maman
même été ou sont meilleurs qu'aux
communautés opérant les enfants tout en
les affamant de tri et de prévenir aussi
c'est la prévention de la malnutrition
passé quand elles dépassent déjà celles
tombe sur les bancs de joseph est aussi
nous aider en conseillant aux autres
maires se bat là il faut faire ça il
faut faire ça si nous n'avons pas tomber
dans la maladie
c'est très facile elle s'adonne entre
eux et là des causeries elle peut se
poser facilement
entrer et elle peut être détecté vallée
à la malnutrition la maman s'est passé
là comment ils veulent sur la 132
je vais très bien oui on y va beaucoup
mieux bientôt pouvoir sortir tu penses
oui il va sortir demain ils sont
[Musique]